the Harvey Weinstein trial wrapped up on
Friday the former movie mogul is accused
of rape and other sexual misconduct
involving two different women
the coming trial could be among the most
watched in recent years here to give us
a preview of what's ahead is Jesse Weber
attorney and host on the law and crime
Network who's been closely following the
proceedings from inside the courtroom
Jessica morning morning you actually
seated directly behind Harvey Weinstein
I could poke them that's up as the jury
selection took place you've described
that jury selection as a surreal process
how so well I think the whole courtroom
experience and the whole experience that
we see is pretty surreal but yeah we
started with 2,000 summons 600 jurors
were called in as of Thursday morning a
hundred forty six jurors were ultimately
questioned by both sides in the judge
and we came to this magic number of 12
jurors three alternates gotta say that
was gonna take a longer amount of time
but here we are seven men and five women
that's right and when you look at that
on the face you wonder does that benefit
the defense with them being
predominantly white males I like to be a
little bit more optimistic but we'll see
what happens
opening statements how much do jurors
put into those I can't stress this
enough so important there is an argument
to be made that you could win over a
jury based upon an opening statement the
prosecution has to set the stage tell
the story the defense has to make him
relatable and sympathetic and if they
make a promise and say they're gonna and
they don't ultimately deliver it in a
trial the jury's gonna remember that so
very important we have two accusers but
we're gonna hear from more witnesses in
this case why is that so important okay
so yeah you have these two witnesses but
these four others can testify to show a
pattern that this wasn't a mistake that
this really was a common scheme that
he's done over the years and also
because the two counts are predatory
sexual assault which is so important
which means if a jury believes he did
this to more than one wimp more than one
woman that top charge is life in prison
they want that the state really wants
those what happened in the Cosby trial
they shouldn't they showed a pattern
it's so important I mean it's one thing
to have to have multiple ones testify
even to uncharged conduct makes the
state's case really this have an impact
in the case out in LA if he testifies
whatever he says could be used against
him in an LA trial one of the accusers
in LA is one of these Molineux witnesses
who's going to testify
in New York whatever she says could be
used in that trial very important and
and how much is the Walker gonna play
into the jurors Minds well they were
asked that question is there anything
about his appearance today that makes
you think he couldn't have done this and
predominately said no you know look I
don't he appears to be not in well shape
I see him every day
yeah whether it's real or not it's hard
to be skeptical but they're gonna see
how there's a great shade know there's
much older yeah and also look this is
the way he is now you're talking about
something that happened years ago he was
in much different shape all right Jesse
what how long should this last by the
way it's gonna end up in till March so
we're gonna be there for a while all
right Jesse thank you
you